después de seis días de bloqueo político
se percibe una salida a la crisis
generada por la elección del presidente
aquí en italia frente a la incapacidad
de los partidos políticos de votar un
candidato aceptado por la izquierda y
por la derecha
representantes de los principales
partidos políticos italianos se
reunieron esta tarde con el actual
presidente sergio mataré la y le
solicitaron que se quedara al poder que
aceptara un segundo mandato explicándole
que está en juego la estabilidad
política e institucional del país
fuentes que asistieron a este encuentro
indican que es sergio mataré la aceptó
esta propuesta una propuesta que debe
ser en todo caso avalada por un voto en
el parlamento italiano desde el cual
tendremos los resultados en las próximas
horas